I mean Drew I was so excited to get out
here I was trying to like bust through
the doors I literally was like screw the
intro I gotta speak from the heart
is most importantly today is also not
only is there the most special person
here but it's a very special day it's
your birthday
I mean
oh my goodness happy birthday thank you
thank you thanks you guys and thank you
drew you little peanut thanks
like that I I want to be here 51.
what okay
I would love a piece of advice for when
we wake up in the morning what's one
thing that you advise like or do for
yourself in the morning
to go and be you that day okay well what
I do in the morning is I work out okay
every day every day oh pretty much no
Drew really you just it's like you just
need you've got to do hard cardio to get
that to get yourself I'm sorry you do
I'm sorry you do is we eat it in our
bodies we needed but we need it in our
brains your brain needs it how long
you find something that actually makes
you feel joyful while you're doing it or
it won't work because this is not going
to get her done
okay that's good that's okay all right
then I'm gonna do it in the morning in
honor of you I'm gonna start and I've
got to be
consistent with it
I um I also admire you so much in your
philanthropy you work with save the
children prolifically like prolifically
this is not this is not a check-in for
you it's a lifestyle I mean
I had an opening and saw a way to be
helpful to our kids my mom grew up
really poor in rural Oklahoma I grew up
in West Virginia where I was middle
class but surrounded by generational
rural poverty and I was just like people
kept coming to me to do all these
incredible things all over the world but
and it all needs to happen thank God for
anyone who has any heart for
philanthropy philanthropy but I was
seeing who's helping Kids In America
who's helping kids this is a huge
country and most of it's rural so those
kids are suffering and who's helping
them I mean and so I went looking for
who that was so
somebody pointed to save the children
and Mark Shriver as the people the
organization and the the guy who was
doing the most to help kids in Rural
America I went there and I've been there
15 years and I will say that after 15
years I more believe in the mission and
in the way the work is done than I did
then so that's saying something I mean
it it really is
[Music]
all right so
you were you are close with your family
like you go back home and like plug in
and root in to your hometown yeah if
you're from the mountains you got to go
back to the mountains I mean I grew up
in a town that
um Charleston capital of West by God
Virginia
um I grew up in a town that is
where it Community matters where if my
mom wasn't home after school she was a
teacher that um I went to Marge Aldridge
our neighbor and she had the key and if
she didn't I would go to the Moors and I
would go into their pantry and help
myself you know what I mean like you
were just you you were looked after by
people if you were doing something wild
there was a grown-up to grab you by the
shoulder and put their finger under your
nose and say uh-uh there too
you know what but how lucky how how
lucky to have that that's just I have to
say that I think the sense of what you
learned growing up and everything you
just said about your hometown is such a
springboard for so much of who you are
and how you behave in this world and I
think you've brought your hometown to
the rest of the globe and put it out
there it's so beautiful it looks nice no
but it's true that's nice that makes a
lot of things trapped in our
conversation well I mean we mentioned
that it's your birthday today I think we
need to kick it up a notch and let's get
a change of birthday scenery around our
hit it
[Applause]
all right
I went deep now we're going loud
[Applause]
thank you so much
oh my gosh it's so true we were the
Swiss bringing each other's there she
goes your bananas I was like I certainly
am but this surprise is very meaningful
and it comes from your hometown in
Charleston West Virginia from here on
out April 17th will be known as Jennifer
Garner day in Charleston
and that's not
the mayor herself Amy Goodwin is here to
tell you about it Amy good
what Jennifer it is with great pleasure
to honor you for your commitment to the
Arts your passion for West Virginia
you're generous and giving spirit we're
honoring you with the key to think
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you Amy Goodwin and the City of
Charleston West Virginia she's so kind
to my niece
yeah thank you mayor Goodwin she's
amazing oh my gosh are we sitting back
down there
campaign I know it's a whack
wow
um let's Okay I would love to honor your
body of work
um
are we doing now
[Music]